- [Voiceover] So, we're
told, consider the formula
Y is equal to two-C over P,
where Y represents the carrot yield.
So, Y represents the carrot yield.
C represents the number
of expected carrots,
and P represents the number of plants.
So, P represents the number of plants.
Select an appropriate measurement unit
for carrot yield.
So, the key here is to realize
that we can treat units
like we would treat algebraic variables.
And so, for example, over here,
if we're saying our yield is going to be
two times the number of expected carrots
divided by the number of plants,
well, our units are going to be...
Well actually we could put
some numbers in here actually
just to make something more interesting.
Let's just say that C is equal
to 10 carrots,
and I'm just making these numbers up.
Just, hopefully, it makes
sense what I'm about to do.
And let's say that P is equal to,
I don't know, 30 plants.
P is equal to 30 plants.
And so using this formula, Y,
Y would be equal to
two times 10 carrots,
two times
10 carrots,
divided by P,
which for this case is 30 plants.
30 plants.
And so two times 10 carrots,
that's going to be 20 carrots.
So we can write the numerator
as, this is 20 carrots,
divided by 30 plants,
and so that is going to be equal to...
You could divide the numbers.
So, it would be 20 divided
by 30, which would be 2/3,
2/3, and then the units
would be carrots per plant.
2/3 carrots per plant.
Carrots per plant.
And once again, the whole point
of what I just did is just to
see what the units would be
for our carrot yield.
And we can see the units
would be carrots per plant.
And I put the numbers
there just so hopefully
it makes a little bit intuitive
sense of what we just did.
As we algebraically manipulate
or mathematically manipulate the numbers,
we do the same thing with the units.
And so, when we try
to find the appropriate
measure unit for carrot yield,
which I had never heard
of before this video,
we see it's carrots per plant is
the appropriate measurement unit,
not carrots per plant-squared.
That would have been the
case if we were squaring
this P, over here,
or plants times the
square root of carrots.
Well that would be more if we
were taking the square root
up here and we weren't dividing by P,
but we were multiplying by P.
But the general theme that you
could see is this constant,
this two, didn't affect
what happens to the units.
But what did matter is
how these variables relate
to each other.
We're taking the variable,
C, dividing it by P.
So, whatever the units were for C,
we divide those units by the units for P
and we get the units for yield,
carrots per plant.